you're stealing the show in front of
your own fans sum up your feelings after
day three yeah I'm very happy because
I mean first the rapid stage is over
because I'm always you know working on
playing beats and secondly you know
that's um I think I have played um yeah
quite quite some uh
quite quite a good stress and um
yeah of course some games were you know
not that great but um our overall it's
like possible it's a very good result
especially today against the mvl take us
through this game because this was
a masterpiece and we were discussing
about this a little bit with Gary you
mentioned to him he said that you had
some preparation in this line after game
against arnish in Bucharest you
Unleashed that preparation today
I mean okay it's a draw yeah but um of
course but um yeah I had it in like uh
already in January 2022 I got the file
about this like but I uh of course when
I play Daniel so I I uh like I hadn't
expected it and it was you know
difficult to memorize I like to recall
what I had in the notes so I so I played
it safe this time I decided to play into
Vari and to play Rook A4 which is
um here yeah uh I mean I see foreign
and here this is critical line probably
kind of false and
okay he's Queen sacrifice yeah here I uh
I I
like I expected Knight H5 to be played
uh this is like very a very strange line
yeah like this yeah it's like clicking
F2 another four episode one
um
and here there are there are like
many moves I want to play I think
okay four here I mean it's just some
draw yeah but I'm some crazy yeah here
for example I think they're like
yeah H6 and G5 are okay but H5 is not
you know it's like it's very uh if it's
the position I I wanted yeah but uh 97
is um sorry on this one yeah here yeah
uh now I thought I'm slightly better
actually uh here this bishop D4 is very
sophisticated movie I mean Castle looks
more natural but I'm
well they kind of yeah Knight B6 was the
move
I still think that yeah take Stakes
Bishop default is for choice right yes
but um
um yeah but it's like you know the game
and um
and if I'll be sure before you know it's
like Ultra accurate because the balance
is really protected so that I can play
93. okay that makes sense keep more
pieces on the board yeah yeah and here
okay I mean Knight C5 could have uh also
we can play them but um
yeah I thought it should be too
and I'm 96
will be four like
um it seems like you're the one having
fun yeah yeah I'm like it's probably
looking for some Perpetual along the way
along the lines I mean and here I I
think it's like very very nice position
for white because I'm
ultra solid and I will consolidate and
start emerging my zip on yeah and
it's like very difficult I think to
oppose this one
and
um yeah here also like Bishop 183 is
very natural I mean maybe some E5 also
96 was the idea but okay I thought it's
very very reasonable and yeah and here
don't you feel like you're uh yeah I'm
no I I mean Bishop takes D5 was very
weird
uh yeah to be honest I don't get it like
um I I mean I would have never done it
with black so
um yeah but maybe
yeah yeah it's just yeah it's extremely
unpleasant and here of course the point
is
um after Queen takes d500 of course yeah
before okay yeah maybe this is what he
yeah five rugby foreign
uh yeah but it was very strange actually
yeah because this position looks kind of
hopeless in the wrong run for him
because eventually every Consolidated
like place my Rooks I don't know C1 D1
yeah and uh step back with my bishop and
then yeah so and here I mean okay it was
a screen for was very unexpected
yeah I I mean yeah and here it was I was
very surprised yeah because um I could
have played like everything I was
actually wondering if uh
yeah so I mean I can do whatever I want
but um H3 you know like D6 I also for
this interesting yeah but after H3 I can
just you know ignore or even take and
because my Bishop is getting active yeah
so I was I spent like I don't know five
minutes on the small H3 I'm not really
checking Community design there so just
make sure there's no lights coming
around G3 yeah yeah that's important
some checkmates well uh last year you
won it you are the defending Champion
but after a rapid portion you were
actually in the third position right now
you have
I think a two-point lead or like a one
point lead over Lavon three points over
Magnus sitting pretty so definitely
um improved on your result a lot of
games still uh to be played but as you
mentioned you do prefer blitz so we're
looking forward to see you tomorrow yeah
thank you guys back to you thank you
Christian and thank you dude